[Music]  [Applause]  now maybe my queen  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the people are in a panic about Hades  every time we open the barrier we're  exposed to danger  we can't risk having another villain  escape  a little susceptor in the Queen's crown  oven stolen  this sleeping spell spreads throughout  Oregon we're trying to discover which  villain has perpetrated this evil  the only thing more powerful than the  curse of the scepter is Hades ember I'm  supposed to protect Oregon I felt all of  my flowers slipping away unless I get  that ember it's game over  you shouldn't have come here lives are  in danger this is a job for pirates I  need that to break a spell  [Music]  No  you  you